cette saison des fêtes arrive un jouet pour lequel vous
mourrez tout simplement votre nouveau meilleur ami est
de retour avec ses rayures emblématiques et ses
yeux réalistes ce bon gars est toujours prêt à
s'amuser vous aurez envie de garder un œil sur
lui, vous ne savez jamais quel problème il  Je passerai au
suivant
si vous perdez sa trace, ne vous
inquiétez pas, il retrouvera toujours son chemin vers
vous, ramenez votre ami à la maison jusqu'à la fin,
car si vous ne le faites pas, vous êtes mort, vous m'entendez
mort, démontage des pièces du corps.  et
autrement peut être requis. Good Guys
n'est pas responsable de m'accrocher
mutilation amputation lacération
strangulation blessures corporelles ou décès de
toute sorte surveillance d'un adulte
[Musique]
recommandée